[Music]
scientists have long thought mozart's
music can be a tonic for mind and body
but now some believe it could make a
tangible difference to people's health
a study in the czech republic found that
listening to mozart can reduce
the symptoms of epilepsy by decreasing
the spikes in the brain that bring on
seizures by
nearly a third we think our research is
important it is completely new
that we could find that
acoustic parameters play a major role
until now it was more or less believed
that it is
these emotions uh that
are participating in in this mozart
effect
now we see that there are physical
parameters we can use it
work with that in various fields
professional musicians think it's the
rhythmical flow of mozart's music
that our senses respond to one is the
temple
which is around 60 which is
you know heartbeat and uh and something
that
that i think settles you as soon as you
hear it because
it somehow um relates to to to the
frequencies
of of of of your body and your end of
your
uh heartbeat so with this piece that
we're talking about
[Music]
for some of those living with epilepsy
music has long been a comfort if not a
cure
[Music]
when you find or i found something like
music that helps me to cope with it
and rudely tell the epilepsy where to go
sometimes
that makes it invaluable and i hope that
more people affected by epilepsy are
able to get hold of that information and
use
classical music or whatever type of
music they like might work that can help
them in the same way
this research now paves the way to hope
that music could soon be therapy for
millions
suffering with this disease
milanov celinovich sky news